it was heralded as a big step forward
out of the pandemic
the johnson and johnson vaccine easier
to administer just one shot
and cheaper than the other approved
vaccines but now federal authorities are
urging health care providers to hold off
on using it
the reason of the 6.8 million people who
have received this vaccine
six people have developed blood clots
one died
another is in critical condition critics
say the federal response
is an overreaction they've only found
six
o'clock of this very rare severe
uh unusual clock out of 6.8 to almost 7
million uh vaccinations delivered that's
less than one in a million
to put that into perspective compared to
astrazeneca that is
10 times lower than what you found with
ashley zenica
in germany and four times
lower than what you've found in the uk
these type of blood clots
show up in the unvaccinated population
between 2 to 14 people per
million in the united states every year
but
authorities here at the fda say it's the
combination of this type of blood clot
and low platelets that has raised the
alarm because if doctors don't know to
ask have you had the johnson johnson
vaccine
they can give the wrong treatment and
that can be fatal
officials are urging people to keep an
eye out for symptoms
pay attention do you have symptoms
headache
you have shortness of breath chest
discomfort
do you have anything that resembles a
neurological syndrome
and obviously if you have something as
serious as a seizure i mean you
that's pretty clear but there is concern
that this will only
further increase vaccine hesitancy with
more than a third of people telling
pollsters
they will wait to take the shot or take
it only if it is required
and many say they simply won't take it
ever
officials say they expect the delay to
last just days and the biden
administration says it won't impact
their overall goal for how many shots
are administered
but what they uncover about this could
have a huge impact on the rest of the
globe
as many countries are counting on this
vaccine to get them past the pandemic
patty culhane al jazeera silver spring
maryland